thank you alex alejandro we are indeed
here with the romanian superstar david
gabrielesko after his first draw of the
event david first of all how does it
feel to be facing all these world
superstars uh first of all thank you for
having me christian uh it's a very
amazing tournament i'm very glad to be a
part of it and i hope i could i can play
better in the future and i can
make better results still a big
opportunity for you what uh how did you
handle the news that you will be playing
in this event i was extremely happy of
course i was actually playing in the
bundesliga in the um
in the weekend before the tournament and
i just
saw it like
i just finished the game and had to run
to the airport and just come here but
it's of course uh
it was a very nice news and i'm very
happy to be here you didn't have much
time between the bundesliga and the
start of this event how did you adjust
the strategy uh to play in this event
well of course it's very hard to prepare
against these guys so i just try to
repair my repertoire and figure out
where would be my weaknesses and try to
improve on that doing that in the few
days i had and
i hope that i had i did a nice job and
i could get nice position well let's
talk about uh this last game of yours
the one uh against voitashek uh
difficult start for you in the first
four rounds
what was your attitude your mindset
going into this game against rather slow
well of course i was trying to push for
a win to come back into the tournament
it was really tough the first few games
especially with so many blacks
but i'm trying to
get back on and i tried to push this
game but unfortunately i didn't quite
get the opening uh position i wanted so
it was quite equal i think uh out of the
opening after i'm not sure when did the
theory i think about here knight b takes
d7 and here i was not sure i mean i i
think i have to play b3 because rook c8
and b5 will come
right along and here i was not quite
sure bishop b2 is of course the most
natural and here i wasn't sure if this
is necessary probably it's just uh just
equalizing but uh queen e2 maybe he even
has b5 i wasn't sure maybe i just take
and uh yeah i i wasn't sure if
uh we are getting complicated yeah
probably my a6 pawn will be pretty
strong oh queenie one was really strong
queen to e1 yeah i missed that that's a
difficult yeah that's really nice
because knight to c5 yeah yeah and also
on rook fc896 i think is the idea and uh
i'm just winning actually
one apparently
okay this is this was not really really
in my calculation this is why 95 i
thought is the easier approach but
probably just minimize my my advantage
okay advantage just because of my uh uh
advantage uh structure yeah pawn
structure and a little bit of space
but uh it was not quite sure and here i
couldn't stop d5 and i think here okay
of course the
most complicated is he takes it takes e5
94 or maybe f4 but uh i thought my pawns
are a little bit shaky there and
his knight 24 would be pretty strong so
i thought that maybe there i'm risking
and i thought that is not really a need
for that so um i simplified the position
yeah i understand
gaming is probably just a draw till the
end didn't feel like there was much
happening no it's it's probably just uh
yeah
every piece is
is matching and uh it's just a draw
you're playing uh wesley saw with the
black pieces in the last round of uh
today how are you going to approach that
one i would try to equalize from the
opening i know wesley
is playing mostly before now but he can
of course try
try everything these players have a lot
of tools in the opening and i'll try to
equalize first and then
see what the position can bring me and
maybe push for more excellent we'll let
you go get your preparation going and
we'll see you in just a few minutes
thank you
and we will be going into a commercial
break stay tuned and we'll be back
shortly